everybody welcome the first episode of
Podcast beyond Greg Miller who's also an
editor beyond who nice that could
replace it exactly it's not good i can't
say scooping and we have a fifth member
in the room special guests get Colin
Moriarty you may remember the man hit
the fallout 3 he had information on
where your father is yep is here I new
columns electro fee [ __ ] yeah I have a
trophy or yes self a miniature of your
Colin works on our guides team requested
be on the show so your company I'm here
now episode 99 but you mostly played ps3
yeah please you belong here yes what
you're saying yep nobody feel me yeah
yum show me their loving show me this
man don't waste another minute on your
cry whether we need we know Whitney the
best is ready to begin as long as we got
each other be really weird about hey
the roper report for some news
the guy asked if you want to do urinal
sandwich shop perks what you want to
save this a legit Eric the past two
seater underage a firefighter powder
concoction it's all the same we're in
bored out here
our own expectations fall away let me be
forced to
here comes this is an email to beyond at
ign.com from Jacob Jacob Jacob Jacob
Jacob white Oh chill out Jake Jake me
shake shake shake off shake off it like
holy [ __ ] like you're looking at it
you go the official list of upcoming
PlayStation software on all your
platforms by the IGN editors I doubt it
I guarantee it oh okay
he was a bed one night this is the log
this is a short version they share a
print version he went to bed one night
and he had a jury that's somewhat taught
about a row of land and then he woke up
and he do on a rota
you know we gotta go I feel like
portillos turned into a hairy boats
gonna throw out of the river of cheese
you know Queenie also named new no no
wait we walked around we went down to a
row famous mom and prop Rock dropship
Ryan clubs Sean rising two beyond the
badging back home hi Sean hi the trauma
and the greater VaShawn oh he's a lot of
the liquor conversational podcast top
picks answer has been in a week he only
does everything calm already home using
my mouse in my 128 key controller
you think we'd ever known
the baby we gotta go
all the way the [ __ ]
we are
bring a refrigerated as a joke because
they know that the props you've been
foretold the baby reacts honey bucket
not Charlie in chocolate factory that's
Charlie Bucket not you thought his last
name within the topic I guess never
happened I was like really excited by
that church are you doing about cakes
dude I recover and our favorite twitter
friend at USP Shuhei Yoshida hello
beyond its back oh my god ladies and
gentleman we are alive from the IGN
office Saturday night it is May
fourteenth we are busting open some
beautiful twenty-first amendment be
right here for come thank you for
getting that no problem you're welcome
and if you haven't heard the whole
reason we're doing this the playstation
network is back in business it is up and
running today this is the day of all new
days it's up to us this time
the SS Moriarty stands tall ready to
defend the PlayStation sure it's an
interview going on bah bah blah Oh
doctor I tell you sometimes I go back
I'll beat you papa I got bad news Chris
Robert what I am firing on every single
cylinder day though you are in for a
ride I'm gonna take you places man like
the Magic School Bus is raining you
freaking floating none